tres años y medio después de su primera
y última visita en 2018 el presidente
del gobierno español se reunió con el
rey de marruecos mohamed sexto en rabat
una visita con un claro propósito y
varias ramificaciones su objetivo
principal es suavizar las relaciones con
marruecos rotas desde 2021 después de
que españa recibiera al líder del
movimiento de liberación del sahara
occidental- del frente polisario para un
tratamiento médico un hecho que desató
el mayor cruce de personas a la frontera
española cuando en mayo llegaron más de
10.000 migrantes indocumentados
precisamente controlar los flujos
migratorios que marruecos ha podido
utilizar como herramienta de presión es
uno de los requisitos que sánchez nombró
en la carta que le envió al rey de
marruecos y que le ha enfrentado a todos
los grupos parlamentarios incluidos sus
socios de coalición por la cuestión del
sáhara occidental' otros de los
requisitos del gobierno de españa' son
el compromiso de evitar acciones
unilaterales o el asegurar la integridad
territorial de ciudades españolas de
ceuta y melilla que están en el
continente africano y en las que
marruecos ha mostrado un interés desde
hace décadas el viaje coincide además
con la publicación hoy mismo en el
boletín oficial del estado de un
convenio entre marruecos y españa que
entrará en vigor el 30 de abril en el
que se comprometen a compartir
información y a colaborar en la lucha
contra el terrorismo la trata de
personas o el comercio ilegal de armas o
drogas pero las consecuencias de este
viaje y de esta posición del gobierno no
son sólo domésticas angelia llamó a
consultas a su embajador inmediatamente
después de conocer la postura de pedro
sánchez con respecto al sáhara
occidental' precisamente el mayor
exportador de gas natural a españa
sugirió un aumento de precios de este
material que afectaría tan sólo a españa
y no a otros socios que también importan
este empresario material desde argelia
precisamente ahora que el gas ruso no es
una buena opción debido a la guerra en
ucrania